hi there it's great to see everybody out
here I'm excited to talk to you about
kubernetes this today I'm Brendon burns
I'm a software engineer at Google
there's gonna be a couple other people
coming up over the course and they'll
introduce themselves so you heard a
little bit about kubernetes in the
keynote and so hopefully if you hadn't
heard about it before you've got a
little bit of context we're gonna go a
little bit deeper today and try and
explain both where we're coming from
why we built it and what's the new
awesomeness that we just built all right
so I wanted to take a little bit of a
step back and give you a little bit of
the history of where we came from Eric
went into this a little bit this morning
so we're gonna kind of move through it
relatively quickly so you don't get
bored hopefully you saw some of that
stuff in the opening keynote today but
in some sense Google a long time ago was
exactly like the way a lot of enterprise
and a lot of other data centers are now
every single app had its own machine you
would use you know ticketing and things
like that to find machines if it's hard
to manage hard to scale painful for
people to operate and so we started to
figure out well what do we need to do in
order to move away from the sort of one
app per machine model and the very
beginnings of that were things like CH
roots putting using nice using some of
the sort of traditional things that
allow you to multi-tenant things but it
wasn't sufficient right noisy neighbors
are a significant problem in that world
where you know some intern running a
MapReduce can totally obliterate your
search infrastructure and that's just
not an acceptable way to run things and
so moving forward we started to develop
technology that enabled us to have
better isolation of these processes and
that eventually led to things like C
groups that Google contributed to the
Linux kernel alright and and what we
found eventually was that actually these
isolation boundaries really helped us
you know maximize the utilization of the
machines to the point where our
utilization of machines is significantly
higher than that
of people basically throughout the rest
of the industry and it's not necessarily
because the people who use the machines
are smarter about packing things but
it's actually just that we have better
isolation and that enables us to pack
things for them and that's really what
kubernetes is trying to do as well all
right so then eventually docker came
around and took a lot of these
technologies and packaged them up in a
really amazing way and Eric said that
you know the container image that docker
came around within the building tools
around that that really sort of opened
up the world of containers and some of
the value of containers on the node to
the broader world and suddenly we saw
this explosion of interest in containers
it was really gratifying I think for a
lot of us because suddenly all of the
stuff that we had been talking about and
thinking about internally we could share
with the outside world and so the time
was right about a little under two years
ago the time was right to start sharing
some of the experiences we'd had over
the preceding you know eight years and
to start listening as well right we were
starting to build out the cloud platform
and we knew that our own internal
experience wasn't necessarily the same
as where our users were coming from and
so we wanted to go forth with this
project and share what we knew but also
accept and build a community around
where people were and that led to the
development of kubernetes kubernetes
it's an open source container management
system again you've heard about it this
morning from Eric so I don't want to
belabor the point but it supports and
you actually hopefully saw the demo as
well in the keynote yesterday it
supports multiple cloud environments it
supports on-prem physical machines it
supports the raspberry pi cluster that I
have you know in my closet and it's 100%
open-source it's written in go if you
haven't checked out go it's a pretty fun
language so that by itself is worth
checking out and it's all available out
on github
alright the core principles of
kubernetes I think this is really
important we when we were going into it
we really wanted to talk about what we
are trying to accomplish when we built
kubernetes and part of what we're trying
to accomplish is that we knew that
people were going to be using unlike in
Google where everything is built from
source people are going to take
off-the-shelf software they're gonna
take my sequel they're gonna take nginx
they're going to put them in containers
and run them and rewriting those
applications just isn't an option for
users and then the other important
principle
sort of runs throughout kubernetes is
that coupling is really really bad when
you take systems and you package them
together tightly and so they're tightly
coupled you end up making changes in one
place that break things in another place
that you weren't anticipating and that's
leads to instability it leads to an
inability to move your software forward
all of the things that are necessary to
build a scalable agile platform they go
away if you couple your software really
tightly together so we really wanted to
decouple our software and then there's a
lot about making sure that we are open
making sure that we you know we really
saw that this open infrastructure
movement was happening it was something
that was important to participate in
you're even starting to see this on the
hardware side on the data center design
side with you know Facebook and others
participating in open data center
designs it's just that's the way that
the data centers of the future are going
to be built and we want it to be part of
that and then also we really wanted to i
what i like to say i don't know people
have had a chance to take a look at the
kubernetes paper that we published
recently but one of the key insights
there is that kubernetes and container
cluster orchestration systems really
allow you to change the primary key of
your data center from being the machine
to being the application right we want
people to start really forgetting about
machines and thinking about applications
instead and so all of this sort of says
we have experienced a lot of the things
that are that are bothering people right
now out there in software development
and we've built some solutions that we
really believe helped you move on and
this is an image that I use in a lot of
my talks and I think it really captures
in some sense what we're trying to
accomplish the challenge of driving
something like this semi truck that fit
that that crash in the middle here is
the semi truck is a coupled system right
there is the cab that is pulling it in
the trailer and as anybody who's backed
up a trailer knows you could be backing
up in one direction and your trailer can
be going in completely the opposite
direction right that coupling that
unintended consequence of some action
because rarely do you take actions that
you think are gonna fail right rarely do
you like push a config because you know
that it's bad and it's going to cause
your application to go down but what you
don't
you know you have all those failures
related to human error is that there's
an unanticipated consequence and that
unanticipated consequence almost always
comes from this kind of coupling all
right and to illustrate this a little
bit more when you think about things in
a machine oriented way when your data
center is machine oriented and you think
about physical infrastructure you end up
with things like this right where your
services are splattered across three
different machines and when you think
about the Machine you think okay you
know I really need to upgrade lib see on
machine number one because you know my
back-end needs this new version of Lib C
and so you go in and you upgrade you
know Lipsy on that on machine one and
your back-end is like I'm awesome I'm
happy to go and then it turns out your
front end is all crashed because they
use that library too but they used a
slightly different version of that
library and there's a bug in the library
that you just upgraded that caused them
to start crashing that's the unintended
consequence right that's why coupling in
in this world is bad and so what we
would really like to do is show you how
kubernetes enables you to create what we
call logical infrastructure and logical
infrastructure basically says forget
about the machines right the machines
disappear below the kubernetes api below
this unified substrate and you start
thinking about your applications it's an
application oriented infrastructure all
of your front ends are the same the
thing that you're going to change is
your front-end the thing that you're
going to upgrade is your front-end and
in this way and you've decoupled all of
these systems from one another and you
don't have those unintended consequences
that cause stability problems all right
another really important part of being
open and being transparent is this idea
of workload portability right there's
all sorts of reasons for people to be in
multiple kinds of data centers be at
their own on-prem data centers private
cloud public cloud colocation whatever
it happens to be there's a lot of
reasons why you're going to be in a lot
of different places and we profoundly
believe that the future of cloud is
hybrid right and so in that world it's
important to have a system that spans
these things right and enables you to
move your application from vendor to
vendor if they're having stability
problems if they're having pricing that
you don't like if a different vendor
comes along and has better pricing
whatever the motivation happens to be
not being locked into a particular
vendor by
using their api's is really powerful for
you as an end user in kubernetes with
its open source aspect and its ability
to run anywhere means if you write
applications to the kubernetes api is
those api's are available and can move
with you wherever you choose to go or
indeed can normalize your environment as
well and so this comes down to the sort
of idea of write once run anywhere which
you know by now kind of has sort of a
bad reputation I guess at some level
because of course there's the asterisks
right it's it's the this is mostly true
this isn't a hundred percent true but
really if you build in a container which
encapsulates all of its dependencies
into this hermetically sealed box and
you deploy and you use services provided
by the kubernetes api you really are
targeting a runtime that is pretty
independent of the infrastructure that
it's running on top of right in the same
way that if you write a program in a
higher-level language usually and that's
where the asterisks comes in of course
that program can run on a variety of
architectures from your arm in the
raspberry pi to x86 - you know mips on a
router or whatever it happens to be and
some examples of this inside the
kubernetes api where we've really tried
to put in some effort into making these
things portable include things like our
networking model where we really tried
to be agnostic we didn't just sort of
say like oh hey this works great on GCE
nobody else can do it anywhere else
ingress is another really great example
of this where we created an API object
for doing HTTP load balancing and
actually the implementation of how that
actually produces a balancer is
developed outside of the kubernetes core
code base so if you want one for your
favorite cloud provider you want one for
your physical you know hardware load
balancer you can build all of these
things and there's one API object but
the implementation can be in a variety
of different ways our services exam are
examples of this as well as well as
persistent volumes where I think at this
point we support twelve different volume
types different distributed storage
technologies different cloud storage
technologies really enables you to be
isolated from the specifics of the
platform that you're running on and then
finally I talked a lot about this
coupling we really think that the
kubernetes api allows you to build these
systems that are
coupled from each other right so that
you can actually have different teams
doing rollouts at different layers your
front-end team can roll out a new set of
the front ends without ever
communicating with the middleware or the
backend teams at all right or the
middleware team can do a rollout and
never communicate with the front-end
team or the back-end team that's hugely
important for distributed teams for
scaling teams up and all of these things
are made available by you know the
ability to isolate things behind you
know a service IP that is unchanging
right it doesn't matter that the actual
pods that implemented a particular
service have come up or gone down the
front-end still just talks to the same
service IP likewise we also want you to
be decoupled from kubernetes itself we
didn't want to provide tools so that you
know if you have a configuration that
looks for a particular environment
variable you don't have to teach nginx
that it's running inside of kubernetes
you can use things like the downward API
to project parts of the kubernetes api
into environment variables that engine x
already knows how to consume right this
is part of meeting people where they are
as well as ensuring that that
application that somebody wrote isn't a
kubernetes version of the application
it's the same application whether it's
running inside of kubernetes or any
other kind of environment and then the
other part of this is you can do this
kind of lift and shift right like maybe
you're not hybrid but you don't want to
be stuck and you can if you get to a
place where the platform doesn't work if
you're in gke and you you reach that
place where you're like no you really
need to be on prem for some reason you
know we'll be sad of course but you can
do that right you can take your workload
out of the gke roll it on over to you
know the on prem pluster or likewise if
you're in a different public cloud
provider right now right we understand
lots of people use different public
clouds you can start with kubernetes in
that environment and build a place where
you know as as we demonstrate to you the
value of running inside the Google cloud
platform you'll be able to easily move
that application across or you can
gradually move your app
from one platform to another and that's
also a key component of being open and
being hybrid all right so that was sort
of a prehistory hopefully wasn't too
redundant with the things that happened
in the keynote I'd like to take a step
forward - now - what's what's next
what's going on here so one thing I
really like to highlight here is the
velocity and Eric's sort of mentioned
this with a high level 27,000 commits
but this graph I think really speaks to
it in a more dramatic fashion you know
we're doing 46 commits a day and that's
averaged across the weekend and so and
we don't actually do that many commits
on the weekends because we all have
lives and so the velocity with which we
are doing this is just amazing and as
well at the same time we're seeing new
people come into the community that's
fantastic as well really excited to see
that really excited to see all of the
companies that are contributing not just
using but contributing as well we really
want to build a community that isn't
just a bunch of Googlers throwing code
over the wall but is really a holistic
community as part of that you may have
also seen the announcement that we've
contributed kubernetes to the cloud
native computing foundation so the
intellectual property around kubernetes
is now actually out and available and
available to the Linux Foundation and as
part of that I want to introduce rich
Steinberg who's the principal engineer
WePay who's going to talk a little bit
about how they use kubernetes to power
we pay so rich thanks thanks
hi I'm rich and I'm here to talk about
we pay and on our experiences kubernetes
so we pay I know it's good to find it
hard to believe but we're about payments
we do payments we start up down in
Redwood City and what we do is we do
payments between individuals we allow
our partners to build the relationship
between the individuals and then we take
over the payment from there and as part
of that we hold credit card data and
we're PCI certified and we do this using
a PHP monolith application that is been
kind of changing with different business
models and now that we're taking off
like crazy this PHP monolith needs to be
taken apart it needs to be broken into
smaller services and and we need a way
to deploy these services so we took let
me move forward so he took three swings
of this back or at this ball the first
was we had some bad sequel that was
running against our database so we need
to move that off so we we knew we want
to do docker and we put this load into a
docker container and we started it
manually and we had it going and it
wasn't great but it really helped the
second was ansible and deploying to
individual machines and we didn't really
know how to do topology at that point so
it was really one VM per I'm sorry one
docker container per VM and and that was
it and we were in Google Cloud and
kubernetes we were part of the community
we were part of the beta program we had
developers inside we pay that are really
excited about kubernetes and and as soon
as it became GA in July of 2015 we were
on board and it really dramatically
changed our whole business because now
we're able to spread our workload across
multiple machines it solved canary
deploys it solved being able to do
rolling deployments it really just sort
of changed us and it's been great and
one of the things that I want to
underscore about kubernetes is that it's
changing rapidly the the problems and
things that we've dealing with we can
look in a road map and actually see
that are gonna help us but more than
that it actually is real use cases that
we have problems with so I want to talk
a little bit about some of the things
that we've done with kubernetes that
have been sort of outside of what
kubernetes can do and then then we'll go
from there so because we're PCI
certified and we talked the keynote
talked a little bit about this but about
not having a gooey Center everything
that communicates back and forth must be
encrypted and that's just from the early
stages of community wasn't available so
what we did is built a sidecar in the
pod with nginx in it and Kubb DNS gives
you a domain name it's like a private
domain and we built our own in-house EA
that serve that C n as the domain name
and that's how we terminated us to sell
another example is since we're PCI
certified when the PCI auditors come in
they want to look at the smallest number
of machines possible they do not want to
look at hundreds and hundreds of VMs
they want to be basically down to the
smallest that possible and a piece in
kubernetes terms what that means a
dedicated cluster for PCI and with a
dedicated cluster for PCI we then need
two dedicated clusters because we need
high availability across zones and so
the need for dedicated clusters and and
these clusters need to communicate with
one another so there's a need for some
sort of inter cluster service discovery
and what we're doing now is we're just
hard coding those service endpoints but
we're looking forward to open Eddy's and
we've also looked at buoyant but
kubernetes is really cool and being able
to solve this problem lastly is secrets
and there's a lot of talk about secrets
today they talked about it in the
keynote and it's a it's a it's a big
thing too you got to consider so the way
we're taking care of it at this point is
using hash a court fault and that's just
encryption as a service and there's API
calls that are scoped to the application
so the really good thing about this is
that it's not putting secrets
unencrypted anywhere on disk ever it's
memory to memory communication and it's
basically leased out so that's been sort
of some use cases and a
I want to say again that kubernetes
doesn't really put you into a box you
can really kind of do what you want with
it and take what they've given us and
and build on top of it and at the same
time it's constantly changing these
problems are being solved by the
equipment IDs team and I'm gonna hand it
over to Tim right now to tell you about
that that's rich
hi everyone I'm Tim I'm one of the
software engineers working on kubernetes
so this is next so let's talk about
what's next so I want to talk about a
few features that were pushing out in
our kubernetes one to release which was
launched last week and I want to talk to
some depth and I'm gonna do some live
demos and we'll tempt the fates and see
what happens so the first thing that
people experience when they have these
distributed applications they need to
figure out how am I gonna update this
thing this has been a topic at a couple
of the talks I know Eric mentioned it
this morning it was part of the demo
yesterday at the keynote we're improving
on what we've done so the goal here run
an application updated with zero
downtime zero visibility to your end
users
we built our rolling update process
completely on our core primitives of
kubernetes there's nothing magic there's
no backdoor api's if you don't like the
rolling update that we've built you can
build your own this comes from a direct
lesson from board where the update
system was really built and tightly
coupled into our system and it turns out
updating different kinds of applications
there's different kinds of requirements
so in version 1 and version 1.0 and 1.1
of kubernetes we had this built into our
Cube control or cube cuttle command line
in version 1.2 we have a new object in
our API called the deployment and a
deployment is updates as a service you
tell the deployment I want you to update
from version X to version y and you take
your hands off and the deployment object
will do it it's all done server-side you
give it a bunch of parameters that tells
you how fast you want to go and what
happens if there's a failure and you let
it run if you add this with graceful
termination of pods what you end up with
is a clean draining update from your
system and you open to connections users
will finish their session
and that said that the old pod will go
away and the new one will come up I want
to walk through a little bit of the
update so imagine for a moment you've
got your service you're wonderful my app
right and backing my application I've
got a replication controller which has
three pod instances that are running it
this is the blue version of the
application if you notice here you'll
see replicas three and the selector is
my app version one right so the first
thing you're gonna do in part of an
update is you're gonna bring up a new
replication controller note specifically
this is my app version two now there's
new replication controller you're gonna
take it from zero replicas to one and
now you've got a new replica running the
service if you notice the selector on
the service is app my app it's version
the independent so at this point 25
percent of my users are gonna be
experiencing my new application this
gives me a really good signal if I can
watch my monitoring that you know maybe
my application is bad and I want to roll
it back well let's assume that you got
it right because you guys are all smart
people so you bring up a new one and you
bring down an old one and you bring up a
new bring up a new one and you bring
down an old one and you repeat this
process until the old version of the
replication controller has zero replicas
left and then you can just throw it away
like I said this is all done server-side
now in the deployment object which
you're gonna get for free if you run
cube cut' will run its new new and the
version 1.2 API the next thing people
tend to run into is scaling I need my
application to be responsive what
happens if if famous celebrity dies I
need to be able to respond with my
application and this change in load so
in kubernetes 1.2 we have launched
something we call it horizontal pod
autoscaler that's a mouthful but what it
does is it takes metrics currently we do
CPU utilization or custom metrics which
are alpha but they work
you take these metrics and you feed it
into the replication system and the
replication can say hey you've crossed a
threshold let me scale you up or yeah
you've dropped below a threshold let me
scale you down obviously you give it
some in max bounds and it operates
within those bounds but again you said
it and you forget it this
you from having to worry about what
happens if something happens on a
different time zone and you're not at a
console and you don't aren't there to
provision new machines this is the ethos
of kubernetes you don't have to worry
about it next thing that people tend to
run into persistent storage right we'd
like to talk about treating your stores
or your servers like cattle right
everybody knows this analogy don't worry
about them they're fungible if they go
away it's not a big deal but the reality
is somewhere at the bottom of your stack
you've got a database right you've got
files you've got storage that you need
to run your stuff so we have an
abstraction called persistent volumes in
kubernetes which lets you create durable
storage in your network or on NFS or you
know you know any one of a almost two
dozen there I'm correct Brendan it's not
12 that's actually a closer to 20
different volume types you store your
data there and then as user you can
claim that data that data is yours
so new in kubernetes 1.2 we have auto
provisioning if you ask for data and
there's nothing in the system that can
satisfy that request will go off and
will make it for you assuming you're in
a cloud provider that supports it like
GCE or Amazon or OpenStack we can
automatically go out and make this new
volume for you what's really cool now is
you can write all your data to this
persistent volume and then you can kill
your application tear it down you know
what my sequel service is done but I
need to offload all that data into my
monitoring system you can then handoff
that data to a different pod because you
still own that data it exists until
you're done with it we never destroy it
until you tell us that it's ok this is
an application oriented use of
infrastructure don't think about the
disks don't think about the I scuzzy
don't think about where they actually
are think about what you want to do with
it so let's do a live demo if we can
switch to the demo guys so I have to
apologize first of all I cannot type and
talk at the same time so I have the self
typing demo but I promise you it is
running live against my GCE cluster
right now so
here we go so this script first thing
I'm going to show you there are no
claims PVC is a persistent volume claim
it's a shortcut I'm showing you with our
Cube control command there are no claims
in our system so let's go off and create
a claim to do this we're gonna look at
this little blob of Y amel you can see
here the claim is called a PV
provisioning demo it's existing in the
demos namespace what I'm asking for is
something that is read/write accessible
and I want 10 gigabytes of space and so
just like that it's been created and
we're gonna take a look at what we've
done with the describe command and it
shows you here that we have a precision
volume claim that is already in the
bound state what that means is has
already gone off and created a volume
for us and bound it to this claim and it
has satisfied it with 10 gigabytes so
this loop is actually going to do
nothing because it happened so quickly
so here you can see the short form it
happened 33 seconds ago that's my proof
that it's real so here I ran g-cloud
compute disks list which shows me in the
Google compute engine here's the list of
disks I grabbed for the ones that I know
that it's gonna match and it's gonna
match this dynamic disk so now I'm gonna
go use this again here's a little blob
of yeah mole that shows me a pod the
important part here is what the pod does
it does an SH see which says go run this
shell command it's going to touch a file
called /pv slash whatever my current
host name is we set the host name to the
pod name so you can see that this file
gets created on the pod and then it's
just gonna go to sleep
and just like that my pot is created and
it's probably already running before I
can finish typing it out so you can see
its schedule that's been assigned to
minion I a 9n and we'll wait for it to
give us a running status so that we can
actually go poke at it okay it is
running so I'm gonna use cube control
and exec into this to give me a show so
I'm now live into this running container
if I LS and the /pv directory you see
that this file is demo bla bla bla that
is it so I'm gonna say
so I've now created this file so I'm
gonna exit this shell and then I'm gonna
go ahead I'm going to delete that pod
now this pod has gone from the system
that running process is gone just to
prove it but my claim still exists I
still own this data and it is still
there and it is still bound and in
compute engine maybe oh there we go
still exist so now I'm gonna run another
pod right my my sequel finished I want
to go run the post-processing I want to
I want to analyze my user logs or
something that I want to do here so I've
gone and created another pod and that's
gonna check that it's running
and I'm gonna shell into this one again
and what you're gonna see cross your
fingers
is that those files that we wrote before
still exist so there you can see now
I've got two hosts two files that are
specific to the host name and the hello
file that I wrote before now I can do
this any number of times I can keep
handing off the pod from container to
container or the the volume from
container to container until I'm done
with it so let me exit this and say I'm
done with it
so I'm gonna go delete my pod you can
see again that the pod is gone this is
all happening real this is how fast the
system actually operates I've deleted my
claim and my claim is gone and the
persistent volume that was backing that
claim is also gone and if I were to look
at G cloud which I don't think I did if
I were to look at G cloud one more time
it would show me that that persistent
volume has been erased what this means
for you is you are free to work on your
application and not worry about who's
managing the infrastructure not send a
ticket to provision a new volume can you
switch back to the slides please
demo number one it worked
I'm gonna tempt the fates and do it
twice so new also in kubernetes 1.2
multi-zone clusters you guys you were
asked and we heard and we answered so
you can now bring up a cluster that
spans multiple zones gke czar GCE zones
or multiple Amazon availability zones
we'll label those the the nodes that
come up on those zones and when you
schedule work we're gonna spread them
across those zones now if the zone blows
up you're safe your applications not
gonna go down kubernetes will say oh
damn what happened to those copies and
it will bring up new ones on these other
nodes this is what it's all about 2:00
a.m. Sunday night you're sleeping do you
want your pager to go off because Google
brought ozone down heck no just handle
it for me right so I'm in email in the
morning I'll take a look this is what
it's about
so there's zero changes to the
communities API you don't need to know
about zones all you need to know is that
when you provision this cluster you
brought it up in multiple zones this is
GA in version 1.2 the code name for this
project has been called uber Nettie's an
uber Nettie's is going to continue to
evolve we're gonna build out a more
federated cluster model in upcoming
versions of our system this is what we
called uber Nettie's light so the next
thing that people talk about Brendan
mentioned this ingress l7 load balancing
we built the core of kubernetes around
the idea of l3 and l4 load balancing
because we wanted to be really agnostic
to applications it turns out
unsurprisingly a lot of you are building
HTTP based applications and you want a
way to get HTTP into your cert into your
clusters so again you asked and we
listened we've built a new API object
called ingress ingress will allow you to
describe a map based on hosts headers or
based on URL paths that will take
incoming HTTP traffic and route it to
various kubernetes service backends so
now again you can build out your micro
services you can have your contact
manager as one application and you can
have your email box as another
application and they can come in through
the same URL and be spread out into
these different services this is
literally how Google operates we have
implementations of the end
the ingress API against GCE there's one
against Amazon that's being developed
right now H a proxy and nginx what this
really means is if you want to run on
premise you can totally do it you can
run H a proxy on your premise you can
pick up your application you can move it
to GCE and you can get all the awesome
power of the GCE load balancer API if
you saw that talk yesterday the reality
of these cloud provider API is that
sometimes they're complicated and if you
learn the GCE look at load balancer API
and then you want to move to Amazon then
you have to learn the Amazon load
balancer API and these two things can't
be any more different and you don't you
don't want to deal with that that's
that's a mess that's coupling so ingress
gives you a way to uncouple from that
the next thing people talk about and
rich mentioned this with respect to his
his stuff that we pay his secrets you've
got to authenticate your applications
you've got to give them access to a
secured something I don't care what it
is maybe it's an SSH key maybe it's an
API token maybe it's a password in plain
text in a file you have access you ever
need to access these things but we've
all read the 12 factor manifesto right
12 factor says you put your
configuration in the environment right
well kubernetes is the environment this
is where you're getting stuff so we are
now giving you an API to manage your
secrets through our unified communities
API through the same cube control
command-line interface through the same
yamo objects with the same semantics as
everything else you inject them into
your application late bound you you know
you write in your API you run your
application you join these two things at
the very last second they are written in
a temp of s so you never write to the
disk they're only in memory and you can
then access them as files or environment
variables from your application so let's
do a live demo we switch to the demo
slide our demo screen thank you all
right
so like everything else there's a little
bit of llamo behind it I'm going to go
off and create a secret it is called my
secret password it is a type opaque it's
not a TLS certificate or anything that
we might know about the username in the
password our base64 here simply so we
can stick binary data into this Yambol
file
I like everything else we just run cube
control create - f it goes off and
creates my secret now I'm gonna go off
and create a pod again all this pod does
is go to sleep but it mounts this secret
you see the volume secret here it's
going to mount it at the slash data
directory so let's create the pod
and the pot is there and it's running
and again I'm gonna shell into this just
to show you what we've got so if I look
in /data now I've got this virtual
directory that is password and user name
so I can cat slash data and you can see
that it's me and I can show you my
password
and I log out of that pod that's it my
pod is now running if it was an SSH key
I could then use that credentials to get
into my SSH the other peers or I could
use it as an API token to go into Twilio
or whatever I needed it to be you can
switch back to the main slides now demo
number two so I've only got a few
minutes left but I wanted to talk about
some of the things we've done and are
doing around performance and scalability
of kubernetes we started 1.0 and we said
cumin ID runs on a hundred nodes and a
hundreds a kind of underwhelming number
right people said Google what are you
doing a hundred nodes
the truth is I'm gonna look out in this
audience I'm not gonna do a survey but
how many of you think in your head how
many of you have more than 100 serving
nodes right now right and I mean to see
how it's not that many people but we
heard people said actually there are a
lot of there are enough people out there
that need more than 100 that we decided
were gonna ramp it up so the first thing
we did is we defined an SLO a service
level objective we said we're not gonna
ramp it up unless we can do it the best
right so we set our objective 99 percent
of all of our API calls returned in less
than one second and 99 percent of pods
start up in less than five seconds and
that has to be true on a fully loaded
cluster the first pod and the last pod
and then we use that to test how high we
can go in kubernetes one two I'm happy
to say we're doing more than a thousand
nodes at more than 30,000 pods in a
given cluster with our API server
meeting this SLO now if you don't mind
about the SLO you can probably double or
even triple those numbers and you know
things will get a little bit slower but
this is this is where we are with one
point to a thousand nodes now all those
people who thought yeah I have more than
100 nodes do you have more than a
thousand nodes I bet there's a very very
small number of you out there right
which is fine when you need it when your
startup hits it gold we're there for you
other things we've done in the 1.2
release we
vamped r-cube proxy system which is the
backbone of our virtual IP services
model in the 1.0 and 1.1 release it did
a user space copy which we knew is a
little bit slow and was gonna be
limiting to scalability 1.2 it never
moves to user space it's purely done in
kernel man is it fast for the demo that
we did for the keynote we were getting
ready to get set up and we were
realizing that the load testers were
causing problems and the first thing
that we did was we switched to the IP
tables proxy and all the problems were
gone so if I didn't believe it before
that's it
additionally in 1.2 massive reduction in
the usage of CPU and memory that our own
components use on the system this 4x
number comes from the guys at Red Hat so
don't take my word for it this means
there's more memory and CPU left for you
to run your applications right we want
to be as slim as we possibly can be for
you now this of course isn't good enough
so what's next
1.3 we're planning to massively increase
the scale again I don't want to talk
numbers just yet but it'll be big we're
talking about moving to a binary encoded
protocol JSON it turns out kind of slow
when we ran a profile against our system
the number one hit was JSON Marshall and
unmarshal so we're gonna move to a
binary encoding protocol you'd still be
JSON there if you want it but we're
gonna use our component to component
stuff will all be done through protobuf
and G RPC we also are adding a bunch of
caching and parallelization in our
scheduler so our scheduler throughput
will be massively faster will be
massively more scalable you can see here
our graph from our current performance
metrics we're publishing a blog post on
this I'm not sure if it's out yet but
it'll be soon and you'll be able to read
a lot more about what we've done with
performance and scalability on
kubernetes 1.2 all of this is available
right now kumaradas 1.2 is in the middle
of rolling out to gke right now in fact
it might be done this very day if you
want it you can go to your container
engine you can run the upgrade command
and you can get all this goodness right
here right now
so all that said we have a ton of work
to do we have 800 man years of work on
our roadmap I'm not even kidding and
that's if we only do the things we know
about criminai Diaz is an open project
we built it from the very beginning to
be open source open ideas open standards
open community we do everything in the
public if anybody here has click that
watch icon in github on mokuba Nettie's
repo I feel bad for you because there's
so much going on it's exciting I'm I'm
passionate and excited about this we
need your help we need people who are
using this thing to come in and tell us
what works what doesn't work what do you
need out of the system because we are
listening we want to make it work for
you guys so you can see here we've got
our URL the code of course is on github
all of us hang out on slack all the time
come and ask us questions we have
dedicated people who sit there and
answer user support questions all day
we're also on Stack Overflow and we're
on Twitter you can find Brendan to
myself and many other people there and
come and ask us questions so I
understand we are not doing a Q&A
session now but at the end of these
sessions we will all be hanging out in
the playground we'll grab a quick bite
to eat and we'll be out there to do QA
talk to people come tell us your story
tell us what worked what didn't work I
want to hear from you so thank you all
very much
you